[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got the best
possible news this morning Superman is
going to be featured during the
three-way crossover this year and not
just for like five minutes he's gonna be
in each of the three episodes they're
also using it to introduce the Lois Lane
character to the universe because even
though we know that she exists they've
talked about her we've never actually
seen her on screen so I'll explain
what's going on what the actors have
said about it the producers have already
teased some of the plot and some of the
matchups obviously flash vs. Superman
race so if you're new to the channel
there's a new round of that flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this had to do a little bit of
searching to find out exactly how many
episodes Superman was gonna be in but it
is confirmed all three episodes remember
flash is gonna be on Sunday night which
I know is weird but I'll talk about that
in a second Venera on Monday night then
Supergirl last part of the crossover on
Tuesday night because obviously they're
introducing Lois Lane on the Supergirl
TV show she's gonna be a character in
that universe I think she's gonna recur
during season 4 for a little while I
don't know how many season 4 episodes
she's going to be in but Lois Lane is
coming to Supergirl they're using this
for bat woman and Lois Lane now because
of everything that's going on yeah they
want to have fun with flash vs. Superman
race but also Batman V Superman because
you have bat woman and Supergirl in the
universe now they did kind of a cringy
version of flash versus Supergirl racing
during Supergirl season 1 but I'm hoping
they correct that with a proper flash
versus Superman comic book raised like a
tag maybe at the end of the crossover
used to imagine a version of that
Justice League post-credit scene I can't
tell you how much I appreciate you doing
this I'll bury myself yeah and it's not
like a competition you know well it is a
competition but you know it's not like a
macho measuring thing but if I win
you're off the team
I win
Bruce said something about you having to
take us all to brunch Oh see now that's
cold that's a betrayal
I feel stung by that okay but if I win I
get to tell everyone deal which coast
you know I've never seen the Pacific
which is that way because the Sun and
its
[Music]
if you're not a big comic book reader
the flash is canonically faster than
Superman so if there's any big questions
or you get into fights with your friends
flash is faster than Superman for those
of you asking about Batman now because
we have full-blown Superman Lois Lane we
have bat woman they did say that Batman
is not gonna be featured Bruce Wayne
won't be anywhere to be found during
this crossover I think he's still Warner
Brothers crown jewel in terms of film
franchises and they're just not ready to
let him into any of these TV universes
yet
Titans is kind of the exception to that
because he's gonna be a big character
for Robin but we haven't seen any
footage of how they're gonna visualize
him so I'm assuming that it's gonna be
like shadows or hallucinations
but even though they have all these big
a-list guest stars it's still all about
introducing the bat woman character they
have not confirmed whether or not she's
already taken the mantle a bat woman
when this crossover starts or if
something's going to happen at the
beginning of this that will slowly
inspire her to do that by the end of the
crossover like the way that they
introduced the flash like you'd meet
Barry Allen then he gets struck by
lightning after he goes back to Central
City I've already done a couple videos
about bat woman's origin story she's in
this downward spiral until she almost
gets mugged outside of a club Batman
saves her she decides enough is enough
so fed up with the direction that her
life's taken and inspired by Batman's
actions she takes his mantle without
asking his permission and starts going
after criminals on her own but she has
nothing to do with the bat family at
that point so I don't know how comic
book accurate they plan on being with TV
bat woman like if it's gonna be the same
scenario where Bruce Wayne is kind of
uneasy and not really sure what to do
with her we already know that Superman
and Jimmy Olsen have a pretty existing
relationship with Batman because of that
scene at the end of season 2 it's
happening a lot so people see this big
guy in this scary mask and they freak
out they're running
just like Clark's friend oh you mean I
feel like they're more frenemies they
still have been confirmed which earth
Batwoman is gonna be from because
they've referenced Batman Bruce Wayne on
both earth one Oliver's reference during
arrow season six then the one I included
from supergirls earth in how much they
intend to push this Batman Superman
relationship with Supergirl and bat
woman going forward because I think the
idea is is they expect the bat woman TV
show to go on for at least five or six
seasons and it seems like some of the
arrowverse shows are winding down so I
think what happens is if if that woman
is a success and they start airing
episodes next year what'll happen is is
if they keep going after Supergirl goes
off the air then Supergirl which has
become a character on the Batwoman TV
show the same way that Oliver and the
arrow characters would pop up on the
flash after that show goes off the air
if the flash is still going because it's
a crossover obviously the villain is
gonna have to be somebody pretty big
there's been rumors that it's the court
of owls but I haven't heard anything
definitive CW has not confirmed anything
so it's still wide open you guys can let
me know though what threat do you think
is big enough specific to the Batman
mythos because this is all about bat
woman that's big enough to warrant
Superman coming into the picture with
Lois Lane
Supergirl arrow in all the flash
characters they did say that because
they couldn't go bigger than crisis on
earth X the next best option was to do a
more character focus story so even
though it's going to be smaller in terms
of scope you still have to have a really
big a-list villain to warrant all these
people coming together right now all the
shows are filming around their fifth
episode they just started episode five
of the flash they just announced they
cast the person that's playing killer
Frost's father is this person here from
Veronica Mars so they're actually not
going to be filming the crossover
episode until we get closer to
everything premiering in October so
about the time we're watching the first
couple of episodes of everything that's
when we'll start to get all the
behind-the-scenes teasers
maybe we'll get an official Batwoman
Costume reveal then around late October
early November they'll start dropping
promos for that I think it was early
November last year when we got our first
trailers for the actual cross over but
they marketed in different ways every
year so let me know in the comments what
do you guys most hype about
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner from my last big DC video bird
seven one eight please email me on the
about page of my youtube channel so I
can get your contact details click here
for that new Captain Marvel teaser and
click here for my other new flash video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]